[Music]
y'all know that Netflix is thriving
right now right you buy stuffs nah I
should've done huh is it too late what
do you think yeah yeah just wait for the
next graph I'm away okay mix Christ I
mean best to get to myself yeah exactly
that's what you need yeah you see you
see oh goodie looking oh yeah oh [ __ ]
boy yes funny when people don't know how
to fly to the big legs like tiger
I thought you'd almost flex like Tyson I
love how Tiger flexes you guys got to
all ask tight cut effects his eyes go
red and he goes his good form he does I
was like who timed that [ __ ] who taught
him yeah whoo this whole family I can't
even think of one person like a buff has
baby I feel like you'd beat me in arm
wrestling that's right now his hands are
definitely way they're great he's pretty
strong pretty strong I'll do this [ __ ]
blew my mind though man so netflix pays
2.4 million per episode to turn a korean
webtoon into a live-action kdrama burn
huh yeah that's like some Game of
Thrones money dude no Game of Thrones
was 30 million episode 1111 or something
towards the end right maybe yeah
why 2.4 million it's such an odd number
well I'm sure there's other the math it
out maybe is the average and how many
episodes you know I don't know tell me
anyways I have a trailer we could see
what this is all good and webtoon is
actually it's it's a thing that I follow
it's like just you know all these
artists can get together indie guys
whatever and you can just draw up comics
and [ __ ] and it's pretty sick yeah and
so um I don't know if these guys are
like homegrown homemade but I think it
is and it's got a huge following is it
gonna be Korean or is it dumb dirty
I don't know I haven't watched it so
we're gonna watch it together
onion
[Music]
it's gonna happy Oh
oh my yeah it's pretty easy
weird [ __ ] is so traumatic we're ten
seconds in
I'm Huck did I just killed myself to
that hotline No
it's pretty intense ding-dong
[Music]
but these started to get weird it's
always a girl three babies open the boon
I got the children wait they turn into a
live-action weight just based off of
that is there more no there's well
calculate you could follow it on
webtoons this is the basically the
synopsis the synopsis is after an
unexpected family tragedy a recluse high
school student is forced to leave his
home only to face something much scarier
a reality where monsters are trying to
wipe out humanity now he must fight
alongside a handful of reluctant heroes
to try and save the world before it's
too late
yeah so I just [ __ ] crazy sounds cool
it is [ __ ] crazy man and I mean
there's already a following behind it so
now they're gonna turn it into uh like a
live action I think it's [ __ ] sick
Umbrella Academy - I never finished it
yeah once I start emphasizing I lost
interest - you guys are the reason
there's no seasons so I don't know if
you guys know uh this director but he's
a kdrama director um and his name is Lee
Young Buck Oh him
yeah I'm still following my vine really
Lee Young bad yeah yeah no yeah that's
the king bed oh okay maybe maybe y'all
know but he's done international hits
such as mr. sunshine descendants of the
Sun in The Guardian nice the Sun yeah
Guardian and a lonely great God he's a
big son lover actor son King who played
son Oh on Netflix I'm saying this for
the fans man cuz I know
they [ __ ] love this [ __ ] yeah Oh song
yeah son Oh on a network a son son son
love alarm alongside Jim Legion of
goodness scene David so a Korean Korean
Korean he's the actor just to put a face
on a kdrama actor okay okay he looks
just like that he doesn't look like the
curtain right isn't that [ __ ] crazy
they pick like the perfect shows Korean
movies are amazing it is like they are
just at the forefront of asian
entertainment I think right now they're
really good at pulling
out the [ __ ] drama but the actors are
you think something better
I don't know how I better buy I think
that just the wide range of stuff that
they could do because their parents are
so mean to them growing up let's say it
makes for good concert it's like every
parent's like Jackson five parents you
know what it is - I think like a lot of
the stuff like they go there like
meaning like maybe out here people were
kind of cautious but this goes straight
to I'm a Q myself my whole family died
yeah yeah like and I'm like oh [ __ ] you
know it was a one-minute trailer but
that made me go I got to see what the
[ __ ] is gonna happen
oh damn so he doesn't kill himself
because he has to fight the monsters in
the world but yo he still hasn't
conquered the monsters in his mind you
know what I guess maybe I dated a Korean
girl four years out to you part Oh
dating dating Koreans though is like a
kdrama level of drama that you go
through is like wow your life is an
emotion though I remember being we were
15 years old and her getting into
arguments with her parents we're make
she would tell her mom mom you hurt my
feelings she'd be crying her mom was
like you only 15 you don't have feelings
we just have to go into a room oh my god
my Korean ex-girlfriend broke up with me
because I she says that she loves me
more than I love her so she goes I think
I think that I love you more than you
love me
oh that's like a nicer way of saying
it's not you it's me
30 seconds later but this she's right
it's true cuz if if you loved her more
you would pick up the phone she was
waiting for you maybe it wasn't 30
seconds okay what ended up happening was
I was shocked cuz she said that and I
was like ah and then she hung up on me
and I was like what I didn't even get
time to think and it was just like I'm
sorry what I'm sorry and I'm like can we
talk about it
she was in episode 2 like what is
happening it was some crazy [ __ ] man and
a lot of like animes and just like just
Asian dramatic cartoons or getting
turned into live-action shows and I'm
like and so they're turning you know
avatar into a live-action shotgun so
Netflix is working on turning that into
a live-action show and I hope they do
justice to and so to avoid that no white
people yeah exactly so they're casting
real Asian actors and it's the some of
the original show runners from the cards
are they casting you well here's the
here's what's [ __ ] up right I wasn't a
good Aang I was looking at a potential
Sokka right I figured it would any maybe
it made more sense but speed of me being
too old so I hit my a manager I'm like
April what's good with the what's the
news on the [ __ ] Netflix avatar [ __ ]
you looked into it they're not casting
yet it's all pre-production but they're
casting strictly teens there was no you
know they're young and I need to find a
team there was adults in it well yeah I
mean was that any like Middle Eastern
Kurt I want to be uncle Iroh I could be
the hip or you yeah I [ __ ] tweet it
and ones like you should be the cabbage
guy the cabbage
he's about cabbages that's all I know
about it yeah save you guys you can
watch it I'd been watching I want to be
in it though I feel like it was our era
of like really good non-japanese
produced kind of anime stuff was back on
it's number one training on Netflix
right now and it's better than The
Legend of Korra I think the original one
wait you have you haven't watched no
I've been meaning to I think most things
that the original ones are better
yeah I'm [ __ ] man it was good dude did
you like the avatar the last airbender
movie and with the m9 hahaha dude it was
bad it was that yeah but the cool thing
is no now it's like I think they're
doing justice to the stories instead of
just like taking it and then kind of
going well I think the demographic would
just want to see more white people right
that's that's one of the great things
that came out of like hyper woke culture
is that like thank you yeah but I'm
still not getting casted are you
auditioning no my DM can you please be a
part of this project you're not even a
fan of the work like you should get
casted for something that you like give
a [ __ ] about he also tells on camera
that he's not a fan I know right you
just said that you I don't like that
[ __ ] but it's not like that Shabana
being it that's exactly what cuz they
want yeah it's cuz I know they're doing
the new street fighter or whatever right
well usually proxy pokemons Oh
I never watch poker game pokemons no but
if it's not a Pokemon no he's one of the
trainers oh my god that's really cool
so there's Brock there's ash there's a
Charmander there's the [ __ ] rocket
the funny thing is though like all the
things that are coming out the people
are gonna get it are your friends like
the people that we all know in this I
mean I sure hope so
what do you mean like like Brandon sue
who yeah yeah yeah yeah alright good I'd
be watching her auditioning for this job
Oh subbu would kill it how many times I
see him and I was just watching
community and he's like 5 years old and
I'm like you think I'm like what the
[ __ ]
I feel like sue who would be Zuko yeah
he wants to be I don't know he doesn't
work he has a similar voice he sounds
like well that was our good friend Dante
too
yeah mm-hmm it's not like fun part a
plan that's exciting man ok as long as
that [ __ ] pops then it just it opens up
the market for more and more movies you
know as long as I'm rooting for
everything even when crazy which agent
was coming out I was like even if this
shit's trash I'm gonna tell everybody
it's amazing yeah I want to be uncle
Iroh is he a crazy rich Asians
no he's in Avatar buddy the old man hmm
I think Bobby Lee would probably be
better my robot
um recast yourself in your own
imagination Joe shows up at the audition
he sees Bobby
nah you're better yeah that's how much I
love the arts so much where I'm like
take the millions take the million
[Music]